[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
madden football is the home of super
bowl 56 and this historic matchup is
brought to you by ea sports it's the
ravens and the hawks and it comes your
way
next ea sports coverage of the national
football league is on the air
tonight it's all on the line we play for
the lombardi trophy as it'll be the afc
champion baltimore ravens
taking on the nfc champions
brandon garden and charles davis on hand
and charles you look at the raven
champions of the afc remember they won
super bowl 47 back in february of 2013.
they've been one of the best teams in
the nfl the last decade or so and now
they look to cap off a tremendous season
and it started pretty quickly for them
because you have to remember
ravens history starts in 1996 when the
browns moved from cleveland and became
an entirely new franchise
known as the baltimore ravens and since
then they've won the super bowl twice
number 47 you mentioned and also number
35 in tampa over the giants this is a
proud franchise looking to have their
third super bowl trophy meanwhile for
the seahawks they are back again in the
big game it's their fourth appearance
but all coming since the year 2000
charles they've been in it three times
total right lost two prior right lost
once in detroit to the pittsburgh
steelers remember mike holmgren was the
head coach of that team and then they
lost that heartbreaker to the new
england patriots when russell wilson was
picked off but the win
oh it was magnificent that was back in
the new york new jersey metropolitan
area super bowl 48. remember they just
rolled over the denver broncos and
peyton manning in that one they'd like
to have that kind of performance again
in this one after all the hype it's
finally time for football as we're
underway in super bowl 56. and we will
not have a return so the first drive of
the super bowl will begin at the 25.
russell wilson leads out the seattle
seahawks offense the veteran wilson a
third round pick back in 2012. and he
comes in off of a tremendous game in the
nfc championship round two weeks ago
this has been a team all season long
that's really taken their identity from
their quarterback and he's been very
vocal in things leading up to this game
that he believes that this is their time
and he's gonna do all he can to will
them to a super bowl win
on first down wilson
throwing
[Applause]
had to throw it to the left sideline and
you know the timing's got to be correct
on this one ball's got to be right where
it needs to be and it was that's because
he had great arm strength on that one
able to drive the football quarterbacks
love it when they can show off their
arms
one play has him up past the 40 already
and another first and ten
from the gun it's wilson
he's got his man this is tayden and
he'll be taken down across the 50 at the
45 in enemy territory
pretty good start right off the bat
there with throws one and two he's not
locking in on just one target early as
he's spreading it around a little bit as
this game gets started back-to-back
first downs back-to-back good plays have
him on the move on first down
there's wilson to throw
and hauled in by the tight end miller
and that's good for a pickup of 10 yards
and it'll be second and very short i
don't mean to jump in on you partner but
they didn't waste any time getting down
field did they
three plays three successful plays in
plus territory now this defense on its
heels a bit it seems like they had
something targeted there doesn't it's
like okay we've got a match up we like
coming right out of the gate let's go
ahead and get right to it
now a throw here hauled in he's gonna go
out of bounds but he takes this one down
just shy of the 20.
how about to start throwing the football
four for four on this opening drive oh
he's slinging it and oftentimes when you
talk about slinging it you're thinking
about a guy throwing it all over the
yard not necessarily accurately in this
case though he's honing in on his
targets and he's delivering yeah the
opening script however they drew it up
for this first drive going to plan so
far
and this one almost intercepted
not a good throw there nearly an opening
drive int
they've given up a few first downs on
this drive but getting the incompletion
there that should give them something to
build on and maybe turn the tide
after the incomplete pass here now is
second and ten
wilson will throw again
he'll dump it off complete to lynch
that'll leave him with a third and two
coming up they got eight yards there i
like it i like it i like it get everyone
involved in the passing game and you
know you create those great mismatches
thrown into your guys out of the
backfield and on the first drive that
can also help establish some rhythm
right i think so it gets everyone
involved they feel like they're part of
it and really gets them amped up as they
go forward
a couple extra tight ends in the
formation here as they line up third and
two
and he gets the first down yardage
before he's brought down just outside
the 10 at the 11.
had a chance to maybe limit them to
three if they couldn't get that
and with a new set of downs you got to
take the mentality of the whole thing
right and everyone's looking at the
offense and saying they've got the
advantage the best defenses just say
okay new set of downs gives us another
chance to make a play ourselves and
maybe change things up
now first and ten at the 11.
from the shotgun wilson
and it's caught and the result here a
pickup of eight leaves him with two to
go on second down
good job there to locate his tight end
charles in the middle of the field yeah
he has good pass catching abilities and
if they're able to continue to find him
here in the early going i think it'll
help out his teammates out on the
perimeter you can take the big shots
later if he occupies their attention
on second down lynch and he is in for
the seattle touchdown
with a first touchdown of this super
bowl and a long one of them and the
seahawks are on the board first here in
this super bowl
so i was the passing game that got him
down here but closer to the goal line
it's the running game that gets them
home certainly appears that they love
the defense into thinking that the
passing game was going to be at the
entire drive nice change up there going
to the running game to get them over the
goal line
now the extra point try forthcoming
and this will give the seahawks a seven
to nothing lead
so a nice drive put together there they
go 75 yards in nine plays and it ends
with a three-yard scoring run
[Applause]
now to send this one away following the
score
returnable here for davis
and he'll get it up past the 20 to about
the 22.
so here come the ravens for their first
look on offense
and a glance at the tall signal caller
standing 6-6
and he's been sensational all season
long but he saved his best work for the
playoffs leading his guys to the afc
championship a couple of weeks ago
and now he knows what lies ahead he's
gonna need to play a near perfect four
quarters of football to get his guys to
the finish line
they go play action here on first down
and oh right away he lost the football
dangerous spot for them to cough it up
lucky to have recovered because the
defense got it they were already within
the shadow of the goal post and then
you're yelling at your own defense
sudden change sudden change that's not
what you want to hear on your sideline
that means you got to run out there and
try and stop an offense who has the ball
in a very advantageous position
so they keep the ball but work to do on
second and long
they'll set up a throw
big hole to the 30. and finally brought
down at the 34-yard line
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
after one seven nothing audi a sports
[Music]
raven football here as we begin corner
number two
as they've got it with a first and ten
[Music]
and he stopped immediately there
no gain on the play it'll be second down
ladies and gentlemen that is a force of
nature at the defensive tackle position
yes he's as big as they come but still
plenty agile he's able to make a nice
play there to swallow up the ball
carrier second and ten
back to throw
and this throw incomplete
the defender all over him that time but
it's going to lead to third down he did
an okay job of absorbing the hit just
couldn't secure the football through the
catch and he was right there on the spot
force the incompletion that's something
defenders work on all the time if you're
there make the contact and continue to
work your way through the receiver so
that you can't possess the football and
turn it into a catch
fighting his safety valve here that's
complete
only two yards and it'll be a punt on
their opening possession was that a
receiver
yeah actually it was it was a running
back who was a receiver on the play ike
he's been spending time in the receiver
drills getting his feet down well those
guys out of the backfield they got to be
good agile with their feet he showed the
agility there with a toe tap no doubt
about us like he'd run to ballet school
got the toes down and stayed in bounds
that'll be a 44 yard boot just a yard on
the return as he's covered up quickly
and it'll be seahawk football first and
ten
seattle's offense coming back onto the
field ready for their second drive
they'll be looking to duplicate the
efforts of drive number one that
resulted in seven points in the seven
zip lead well you know how much i enjoy
horse racing right looks like they
caught a flyer out of the gate as they
would say when you're running the big
time races means they get out to a fast
start they're setting the pace making
the other team chase now
wilson the seahawks take over now first
and ten at their own 17-yard line
throwing to start the drive wilson
trying to get it to harvard and it's
intercepted
picked off at the 19
yeah great field position here as the
ball will be at the 15-yard line
they'll take possession already in the
red zone and in a great spot to add
points to the scoreboard and brandon how
many times have we seen a defense with a
lot of field behind them
get even more aggressive right they
think they've got them not pinned down
but in a favorable spot for them and
they took advantage of it there got a
nice interception and set up their
offense in great shape
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
line of scrimmage the 15. it's first and
ten
they'll come out throwing here to start
the drive and that one
and to put it mildly this is a tough
spot defensively they have to come right
back out and defend their red zone but
how about that good first step towards
forcing them to settle for at least
three points
i think they're also thinking bigger
right now imagine being able to stop
them totally and change the momentum
and now here's a carry heading left
and he takes us down to about the 12 for
a gain of three
pretty good level two play sequence
there you foresee in completion then a
very short pickup yeah now maybe bring
in an extra defensive back or two
because you want to try and defend on
third down they like to play those
nickel or sub packages don't they
in danger of squandering their great
field position as they come up on a
third and seven
they'll set up to throw
and he's not able to get away sacked
back at the
22. it's a loss of 10 on the sack and it
leads to fourth
then partner it's safe to say that the
secondary really contributed to that
yeah nichols set five defensive backs
they covered everything nowhere to go
with the football but my question is
why didn't he throw it away
[Applause]
two minutes on the clock in the second
quarter of this super bowl
[Applause]
now the ravens bring out the field goal
unit here from the left hash this from
39.
and this one is right through
and they are on the board but still
trailing it's 7-3
i got the interception but very little
movement after and that forces him to
settle for three and it does feel like
settling when that happens doesn't it it
certainly does but we gotta give a lot
of credit where it's due and that's to
the defense because they ran onto the
field is what we call sudden change
right interception you gotta go put out
the fire and they did holding them to a
field goal
how does the kickoff unit as they run up
and send this one away
no run back here down to a knee and this
drive will start at the 25.
[Music]
coming to the line here to begin their
next drive the seahawks offense and last
time one play interceptions so this
offense they should be fresh
that's a good way of playing it and i
can't wait to see what they decided got
a man it's caught inside the 10.
and they're going to have this in a
great spot way down in baltimore
territory
it's a big hook up there wilson to
baldwin 68 yards i think it's about time
i took my eyes off of the secondary or
the guys with the football how about the
offensive line on that snap they took
care of business absolutely and when he
can stay in the pocket like that you're
gonna get big plays like we just saw
well that didn't take long one play and
we're already looking at a first and
goal situation
incomplete but a penalty flag is down in
the backfield
let's get the call
[Music]
that hold coming from the left side of
the line hands got caught in the cookie
jar on that one and the flag came out
penalty against them
a terrible spot for a holding call is
he'll try again but now from further
back on first and goal
there's wilson
[Applause]
and that throw behind his man he missed
him incomplete the touch of time here
critical for those types of throws he
put a lot of zip on now when needed just
a little bit more finesse trying to get
it to his back
[Music]
an incomplete pass on first down here's
second and goal
[Applause]
out of the gun here's wilson
steps away to his left and he'll slide
to a halt here still a little shy of the
first down marker now the seahawks gonna
use the first of their timeouts as
they'll stop it with just over a minute
to go before halftime
[Applause]
[Applause]
a big play to start the drive got him in
this position but this defense has held
firm since and now it's third and goal
[Applause]
now wilson
to the end zone but it's incomplete
how did he miss it
wide open in the end zone
he's not hurried he's not hit and
somehow incomplete yeah what happened
during film study that's one where he's
just gonna shake his head not be able to
believe it six points go by the wayside
on that one
so out now is the seattle field goal
team
and his kick is right there it's good
and they push the lead up to a touchdown
now at 10-3
so a nice kick there as they add three
to the lead and from what i've seen so
far brandon i think they've been the
better of the two teams here in the
first half so even though you want the
touchdown
i think that's a nice job there to put
three points on the board
[Applause]
now after the made field goal houska
back out onto the field to kick it away
[Applause]
and davis contend just to bring this out
to the 25-yard line
the raven offense gonna take over late
in this first half and with just under a
minute to go they might try to think
about mounting a driver if they can and
get in the end zone could potentially
tie this game up
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
they'll try and start this drive in the
air
that's complete to sure
they'll have a first down past the 40.
they'll take this to the other side of
midfield before going out of bounds
[Applause]
that's a good chunk of yardage it's
going to be canceled out we always talk
about hidden yardage in a game that's
going to count as that because now it
doesn't go on the books but now they
have to make that up again don't they
[Music]
so following the hold they're in a bit
of a hole here with a first and 20.
[Applause]
he'll drop to throw
he finds taylor complete
now the ravens gonna use one of their
time-outs as the clock will stop with 37
seconds to play in this first half
second and nine
[Applause]
he'll look to throw
[Applause]
this caught reception by holmes
and he'll be out of bounds just shy of
the
[Applause]
a nice attacking play that picked up a
heck of a chunky garbage
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good
so the big play gets them across
midfield now for first and ten
[Applause]
they'll look to throw
going right side here and that's
complete
the ravens gonna use the second of their
timeouts
as the stoppage will come with 23
seconds to go till halftime
[Music]
this offense finding its legs now here's
another first and ten
back to throw again
[Applause]
that is caught at the seven
to the two yard line there before
crossing over out of bounds
that's a nice job of working his way
open down in the red zone look that one
in and then made a beeline for the pylon
he didn't quite get there you want to
give him a little extra for the effort
but instead he sets his guys up in
excellent shape with a first and goal
a chance now to get even before the
break as they come up first and goal
they'll look to throw again feeling the
pressure here and taken down a sack back
at the seven
ravens gonna use their third and final
timeout as they'll stop the clock with
12 seconds to go in this first half
now from the seven here's second and
goal
now back to
throw under pressure they got him again
a huge win defensively they're on the
sack setting them back 12 yards
and now third and goal
so we've come upon halftime in the big
one the super bowl as we send you to
orlando to check in with jonathan
coachman at our ea sports halftime
report coach all right brandon thanks
very much welcome everybody to our
abbreviated version of the ea sports
halftime report
first let's get a check on the next gen
stats from that first half for the
ravens and they did not do much at all
in terms of throwing the football in
those first two quarters that's going to
need to improve if they want to race
this deficit
meanwhile for the seahawks they had a
little more success than their
counterparts did in the passing game as
evidenced by the numbers there
okay coach thanks as always this one
still anyone's game as we welcome you
back for corner number three
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
these two teams sat through a longer
than usual 30-minute wait but we're back
in action here in the super bowl
returnable here for davis
that he'll take it up past the 25 to the
26-yard line
[Applause]
the raven offense set to start this
third quarter and they trail here in the
super bowl but fortunately for them
charles very much still within striking
range yeah things didn't go exactly the
way they planned in the first half to me
they appeared to be a little bit tight
made a few as it normally wouldn't but
of course this is the super bowl so
things get a little bit heightened in
that regard i think they have to feel a
little fortunate they're only down what
they are here starting the third quarter
[Applause]
and right side they're going to go
option here
give him 10 yards on the keeper and
it'll lead to a second down you know
despite the scoreline i think they've
gotta like where they are they're on the
road and just one big play away from
getting right back in this game i'm
gonna follow right along with you
because the spot they're in now
is a credit to their defense they've
kept them in it by making the plays that
they've made and that just means you're
one big score away from being right back
there now the question is can this
offense step up and make that play
because that's been an issue for them in
this game
[Applause]
because he feels like he can come back
on third down and pick up the first down
but sometimes you just don't want brake
tendency stay with what you are stay
with who you know and go get the first
down that's exactly what they did
back-to-back good plays have him on the
move on first down
back to throw here
he's gonna flip one out here to his
running back
so he'll be stopped here for no gain and
that'll make it second and ten
that's a simple throw and catch but even
with that completion zero yards gained
so they're behind schedule on down and
distance i think they were hoping to get
it to him he could make a man or two
miss but that window closed quickly
[Music]
third quarter of a tight football game
as we come up on a second and ten
[Applause]
they'll drop to throw
they'll try and set up the screen it's
complete
they do get a yard there but only a yard
leaves them with third and nine looming
as a defense you're more balanced when
you're at zone coverage because you're
able to keep your eyes on the
quarterback and see the play develop in
front of you they're able to keep the
quick pass in front of them and stop it
right at the line of scrimmage
on third down he'll drop to throw
[Applause]
and that is incomplete but the pressure
there on third down forcing the aaron
pass
fourth down coming up the piers are
going to come up empty on this first
drive of the second half still down by
that slim margin yeah and that's okay
you know when you sit and analyze it
they're not happy about what happened
having to go to the bench but this gives
them a chance to let their defense do
some work while they on the sidelines go
over what they're doing offensively and
formulate a proper plan
the ravens send their punter out now as
he's on here to punt it away
this is a way but boy headed straight
for the sidelines
and this one will not be returnable as
it sails out of bounds
here comes the seahawks offensive unit
they'll have it first to begin the third
their drive last time it stalled out
they were forced to take the short field
goal and the key phrase you nailed it
forced to because you know coaches look
at these short field goals as a last
resort right to them that's not how
drives are supposed to end you're
supposed to put six on the board that's
a consolation prize like going to the
county fair
you don't get the big stuffed animal on
that one do you no you don't go top
shelf that's bottom shelf material
[Applause]
it's a jet sweep wilson with a little
pop pass
and only able to get two here stopped at
the 30.
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is lynch
and they get him down but not before he
takes it across the 40-yard line
that's a nice run right there able to
get to the outside and so many times
defenses say okay we've got you hemmed
in
if you're running the football at least
you know where everyone is coming from
you have to worry about the backside at
all that allows you to run with a little
bit more confidence as you traverse down
the field
[Applause]
[Music]
now we've got whistles and movement up
front i think this is against seattle
so that'll back him up
[Applause]
[Applause]
wilson
dancing to his left and he will slide to
a halt with a penalty marker down on the
play
[Applause]
umpire through the flag usually always
indicates holding and that's what we've
got and you know depending on their
positioning where you are on the field
the umpires get different
responsibilities but always always
making sure no one's holding
[Applause]
to throw is wilson
he's gonna loft one deep left side here
and that will be incomplete
would have been a big hitter if they had
connected instead of second down well
you gotta think this sooner or later
they're going to hit one of those but
the coverage has been excellent thus far
and it was again on the last play
[Music]
so they'll come up after the end
completion for second down
now it's wilson
he completes it
they'll wind up getting ten back as that
sets him up for third down
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
one quarter remains here in the super
bowl we'll return with more after this
break you're watching the nfl audie
sports
back now here on ea sports
it's the seahawks with the possession
they also have the lead here as we get
set for the fourth and final quarter
possibly a turning point big play coming
this is third and long
now wilson
going up top for mueller and unable to
connect incomplete
give them credit they took their shot
but it's gonna bring up fourth down well
when you've got a tight end who can run
you've got to give them a shot to unlock
the defense wanna see what they can get
taking the big shot downfield that one
winds up incomplete the seahawks send
out their potter as he'll come on to
kick this one away
[Applause]
it's a 39-yard punt three on the return
and possession will switch hands first
and ten
and now baltimore gets set to take the
field
and it's quickly becoming now we're
never time in the super bowl trailing by
seven here in the fourth
a pivotal pivotal moment in this
football game
[Applause]
[Music]
how about this they'll try the option
left side
two yards the gain on the keeper and
it's second down
i know we can't hear what's going on in
that hubble right now but i guarantee
you at least one offensive lineman is
saying my bad we simply couldn't move
them off the line of skirmish we've got
to do a better job trying to root those
guys out of there
[Applause]
second and eight coming up
now a handoff here to his running back
and he's taken down but able to slip
across the 35.
[Applause]
we'll definitely see some open running
lanes and he's taking advantage of it
right now but that shouldn't be a
surprise defense has the lead they're
playing for the pass first
[Music]
lot of scrimmage the 37 on first and 10.
they'll look to throw here
he's got his man sharp complete seven
yards to pick up there
that's a staple of this offense drag
round to the tight end dave's unable to
use his size to break off much more
yardage after the catch but still an
effective gain nonetheless
second down and three
gonna give this time to the tailback and
he has met at the line of scrimmage and
he goes down right there
calling no gain that time as it's going
to leave him with a third and about
three to go
fourth quarter down to the final two
minutes and we've got a one score game
[Music]
so it's raven football here as we
welcome you back
they face a critical third down now
needing a score here in the late going
he'll get this one complete to davis and
he will have a ravens first down as
they're able to get the third down
conversion
now you're right on the edge of field
goal range you've still got time but get
up to the line of scrimmage and get set
[Applause]
first down now but that clock rolling
he's back to throw
now he'll dump it underneath to his
running back complete
and he'll go down shy of the 40 at the
41.
so the completion good for six yards and
it'll be a second down they're making
steady progress but i see your face
you're worried about that clock i'm
worried about the clock and at some
point you have to have a splash play in
there as well the ravens moving quickly
here's the clock runs
back to throw
and he can't get a throw off he's taken
down what a huge play at this point in
the game
seventh play in this drive coming up but
a long way to go on third down
back to throw
and that is knocked away in the middle
of the field and incomplete what a great
sequence by this defense so far they've
given him nowhere to go with the
football and they just have to make it
stand up one more time because it
appears that they've got their number
can they not have a slip up here and
allow the touchdown
if they're gonna have a shot in this
super bowl they're gonna need this one
on fourth down
as expected they're going for it to keep
the drive alive he'll fire a desperation
throw for the end zone
and did he get the feet down no they'll
say he did not it's incomplete toward
the back corner of the end zone but he
could not get the feet down this will
wind up incomplete so now let's reset
here charles they do have two timeouts
left so they can stop the clock twice
this one's not quite over yet no and
what you're doing on defense you're
going to use both timeouts obviously but
you've got to call defenses are going to
force the issue early meaning you want
that play over fast you don't want to
give them time to dance around in the
backfield or run a wide sweep that'll
take off time blitzel put pressure on
him make sure that play ends quickly so
you can go ahead and keep moving
[Applause]
and i believe the referee's been buzzed
yeah they want to take another look at
this
certainly a big one here laid in a tight
game
they're taking a peek at whether or not
those feet were in bounds and obviously
a good call here in the end zone and not
just the feet how about the hands how is
the ball possessed while the feet are
hopefully
getting down in bounds that's what
they're trying to look at to see if it
all comes together
[Applause]
[Music]
so the folks in new york just gonna wind
up confirming what the officials saw as
this play will stand as is
[Applause]
coming to the line here to begin their
next drive the seahawks offense
they have the lead still a one
possession game but the defense got to
stop they've got the football now just
salted away right exactly that's all the
defense is counting on from their
offense they did their job in a big way
you know they're over on the sidelines
now starting to take their tape off and
hey we've done this thing the offense
has to put it away and that means ball
security absolutely stranger things have
happened
[Applause]
a loss of a yard there to start out that
leads to a second and 11.
and they'll give to lynch out of the gun
and across midfield he goes into raven
territory
ravens gonna use their third and final
timeout as they'll stop it with just
over 40 seconds to go in the game
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the seahawks in victory formation as
they go ahead and take the knee
i don't know why we did it but we went
to their final walk through for some
reason and what did we see their last
playing walkthrough was taking a knee
and celebrating winning a super bowl
they wanted visualization they did it
for real yeah they just scripted it out
defense can't stop the clock and they
can watch the final seconds tick
and on fourth down on is the punt team
sending this one away
and the seahawks are the class of the
nfl
madden football is the home of super
bowl 56 and this historic matchup is
brought to you by ea sports
it's the pads and the teeps and it's
coming up next we are pleased as always
to be bringing you coverage of the
national football league sports
tonight it's all on the line we play for
the lombardi trophy as it'll be the afc
champion new england patriots
taking on yet another afc team the
kansas city chiefs
[Applause]
for the first time in almost 30 years
the big game is back in los angeles
super bowl 56 underway and here's lewis
and no chance to get away as they'll get
him down at about the 17-yard line
so here come the patriots to take over
on offense
they will be let out by their now
44-year-old quarterback playing in his
22nd nfl season
unbelievable the great tom brady and
he's been sensational all season long
but he saved his best work for the
playoffs leading his guys to the afc
championship a couple of weeks ago
and now he knows what lies ahead he's
gonna need to play a near perfect four
quarters of football to get his guys to
the finish line
so from the 17 now here's the first and
10.
they start the drive on the ground with
lewis and right away they're going to
stack him up right at the line of
scrimmage
calling no gain on the game's first play
and it's second down now
well if you look where that play starts
o-line versus d-line that was about one
by the d-line yeah and oftentimes is won
by quickness off the ball who can handle
the guy across from them best on that
play the defensive line did exactly that
now brady
looking for edelman and he hits him it's
complete and he'll get this up to the
30-yard line
[Applause]
now that was pretty they executed that
curl round versus zone coverage and that
changes things a little bit because
against man it's often a tight curl
tight sharply run route again zone
you're just looking for that open spot
that dead area so you may curl it a
little bit wider just to get to that
place and usually a tight window he
fired a bullet in there for the
completion
they will get four yards here on the
first down run and that'll make it
second and six
on every plank you realize it's not
going to go for a touchdown so a lot of
your calls are setting things up for
maybe later in the game trying to
establish the inside run run with
toughness now hopefully get to the
perimeter later and let's face it you
could do worse than a four yard run on
first down following the pickup of four
here's second and six
and he'll rumble for about five up close
to the 40.
all right i know where they're only
going here but those kind of runs
they're gonna open up a world of
opportunities for this offense going
forward
[Applause]
they'll try to run for it lewis and he's
got the first down yardage before he's
brought down at the 42.
defense had a chance to get off the
field here in the opening drive couldn't
do it i know that we go into these
meetings with coaches and sometimes
maybe we can get you know a little bit
numb because they're always going to
talk about how important third down is
aren't they offense and defense in this
case one capitalized and the other as
you said had a chance get off the field
and didn't get it done
so two first downs and that moves the
ball to the 42 now first and ten
now lewis
and not much there at all maybe a yard
up to the 43.
it's
hard nothing but defenders in your way
they stacked that one up really well but
give him credit instead of trying to
bounce it out and turn it into a big
play which might have turned into a big
loss kind of took his medicine there and
took the one yard
here's second and nine
now he'll throw with brady
and on the left sideline he caught it
but out of bounds according to the
headlines but incomplete so the ball a
little late getting there and it's third
down
love the idea love the concept but you
gotta leave a little room on the
sideline so he can fade into it when he
makes the catch that was thrown too
close to it for the receiver to make a
play
now play number seven of this drive but
it's a top third of nine
brady gonna throw
toward the sideline did he keep the feet
in yes he got a bump down says the side
judge and that's good enough for a first
down
yeah he's already got two catches on the
opening drive and they know he's going
to be a handful and sometimes you game
plan for that offensively you want to
make sure that guy touches the ball and
sometimes it just happens naturally and
then you change your game plan when he
has the hot hand you keep going back to
him because he's running routes with
confidence as the game goes on so now
first and ten in chief's territory at
the 35-yard line
here's brady
and it's complete he gets this one to
washington and down to the 20 he'll go
before heading
[Music]
let's make this one simple what a catch
especially the finishing part of getting
his feet in bounds toe tapping and of
course foot dragging a little tapestry
if you will oh i like it
[Applause]
[Music]
on first down one they'll get it inside
the red zone but only for a couple down
to the 19.
[Music]
[Applause]
we're scoreless
[Music]
start of the second quarter and it's the
patriots in control of the football
as they've got a second and eight fourth
coming
[Music]
oh
they'll run it here with blood
and they'll get him down right around
the 16.
another two yard gain there but they'll
need to do better this time it's third
and six
two yards on the first down carry and
then followed up by two yards on the
second down carrot well that's
definitely not gonna be enough to get
the job done wasn't the expression three
yards in a cloud of dust
now they're gonna need six on third down
to keep the drive going so they need six
yards here on third down they're two for
two on third down try so far on this
drive
from the gun it's brady yeah that will
be incomplete they converted twice on
third down that drive already but
couldn't make it a third we always talk
about in-game adjustments how about the
defense did they're able to shut them
down on that attempt
[Applause]
[Applause]
so on fourth down brady will yield to
goskowski for the field goal try this a
33-yard attempt
goskowski's kick is good
and the patriots jump out to a
three-nothing lead
so a nice opening drive on the road you
get the three points part of you wonders
if that might hurt them later not
getting into the end zone well the good
thing is still first quarter and they
didn't come out of it with points in a
sense they could look at positively and
say hey we set the pace in this one i
think that's how they'll go about it
the kickoff unit is out on the field and
they will send this one away
taken at the goal line
and he will make it to the 20-yard line
and no further
so here are the chiefs now as they get
set for their opening drive
they're led by the nfl's mvp in 2018 and
also mvp of super bowl 54 in his fifth
season it's patrick mahomes and he's
been sensational all season long but he
saved his best work for the playoffs
leading his guys to the afc championship
a couple of weeks ago and now he knows
what lies ahead he's gonna need to play
a near perfect four quarters of football
to get his guys to the finish line
rolls will lead the chiefs up first and
ten at the 20.
they'll come out throwing here to start
the drive oh he's going to take a shot
right away
and that's caught inside the 35
and all the way
[Applause]
[Music]
47 yards
so the big play changes the complexion
of things here's first and ten just
outside the 30.
from the gun it's mahomes
forced out to his left
and mahomes picking up the first as he
slides and hits the deck
[Applause]
[Applause]
measure
[Applause]
[Applause]
so from inside to 20 here's first and 10
at the 18.
operating from the red zone now the
homes mahone's hit he lost the football
and it's picked up by the patriots a big
seam and he might go all the way
[Applause]
very very rare we only had
in the first 50 super bowls the biggest
stage the biggest game and we just saw
it happen again extraordinary the
defense has been good and they were good
again there
now stephen goszkowski on for the extra
point
it's up and good and that'll increase
their lead to 10-0
the scoop and score always an exciting
play in football and we witnessed it
there grabbing it off the ground and
then rumbling it into the end zone for
six
[Applause]
then you can bet they're preaching two
hands on the ball here is the kicks away
following that fumble return
here's hardman on the return
and he'll go down as this drive will
start at the 25-yard line
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
the chief's offense about set to begin
this drive and that last possession
really a gut punch you seemingly had it
working you were in the midst of a very
strong drive then suddenly the fumble
and you're watching the back of a
defender's jersey as he brings it all
the way in the other direction there's
not much more i can add to that i
thought you summarized it perfectly
partner you just got to regroup and
start putting another drive together
that's all you can do
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
two minutes on the clock in the second
quarter of this super bowl
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
a reminder coming up at intermission
we'll get highlights of this super bowl
from jonathan coachman of the crew in
orlando for our ea sports halftime
report meanwhile the homes throw here
complete to kelsey and they're well past
midfield just a yard or two shy of the
40.
a lot of tight ends just use their size
and their strength try to occupy some
space and kind of body people away and
catch the football but not this guy he's
a refined route runner makes me wonder
if he took some dance classes in his
background with his footwork
back-to-back good plays have him on the
move on first down
mahomes now to throw
and that is going to be incomplete as he
let him a bit too much well the
incompletion yes but maybe here not the
worst thing in the world no not on first
and ten it actually gives us a chance to
regroup relax just a little bit they
huddle up talk it over then they get a
chance to continue their drive here's
second and ten
and again it's mahomes oh this is
intercepted intended for hill
picked off at the 38
20.
then he takes this one back
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
return for another school
[Applause]
[Music]
for the point after
[Music]
he's got it and it's 17 nothing
so the defense creating some points not
only getting the interception but then
returning it to the end zone for the big
six
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so they'll get another shot on offense
following that pick six and now the kick
is away
here's hardman on the return
and he'll be tackled just shy of the 25.
so now here are the chiefs as their
offense makes their way back out onto
the field and last time decent field
position through the pick six obviously
costly but they can't afford to just
bunker in now all right
good field position means go ahead and
attack on offense try and press the
advantage a little bit they have to be
better with the football on this
position
that didn't bother you too much last
time no because this is exactly what
you're supposed to do you can't have
good field position not try to take
advantage of it sometimes the defense
makes a good play too
now the homes to try again after the
pick six gonna let one fly for robertson
and that is incomplete
took a shot there on first down but he
couldn't reel it in
but i guess that answers the question
whether or not they want him throwing it
again right away after throwing the pick
six on the previous drive yeah not
something conservative or underneath
pretty big shot right there get him
right back in the saddle so go ahead and
sling it big guy
so after the incompletion on first now
second and ten
shotgun snap to mahomes
this one swung out to williams
and he'll be out of bounds across the
30-yard line
they get seven out of that so they're
left with a third and three
[Music]
here's mahomes to throw
and this is caught by watkins
the chiefs now gonna use the first of
their timeout
as the clock will stop with 55 seconds
to go until halftime
[Music]
first and ten here you know if they
could just get three out of this there's
something about narrowing it to a two
score game at half that makes it feel
like much less of an obstacle going deep
here for watkins and that's caught
inside the 30.
now another timeout called for by the
offense as they get the stoppage with
just under 50 seconds remaining in half
number one
[Applause]
[Music]
so now then the big play has them all
the way inside the 30 now first and ten
again they'll throw with mahones
and that is incomplete now the coverage
a little too good there and it's second
down
as his old brain remembers when i see
five wide receivers on the field as a
defender i know the ball is coming out
high they expected it and got there and
popped it free
once again they'll come up on the 26
yard line second and ten
looking to throw as mahomes the tight
end kelsey has it over the middle
nine yards not quite enough and they'll
be left now with third and one that's
not critical about the game there on
second down that was a positive play
because that was a take what you can get
situation got out to the tight end now
gives a much better opportunity to
convert on third down
now you've got to hustle your guys to
the line and get upset
mahomes to throw on third and one
and this is gonna be caught no they say
it's incomplete he certainly had a good
game throwing the ball so far but i
think he was trying to take that from
good to great with that throw trying to
get one downfield
[Applause]
so on fourth down the home's off
harrison butker on for the chief's field
goal from the left hash this from 34.
butkers kick here is good
and they're on the board at least here
it's now 17-3
so three drives now for this offense and
that field goal gives them their first
three points so if you're an offensive
coordinator and you're averaging a point
to drive getting the wrong way to work
aren't you you gotta find a way to
unlock the key to these defenses and put
some big points on the board
[Applause]
[Music]
so not much time to speak of remaining
in this first half as the kicks away
it's taken in at the goal line
and he returns this to the 22.
[Music]
[Music]
the pats at the line ready to go and
with eight seconds on the clock really
not a lot of time to try to put anything
together
and they're just going to run it here up
the middle
and an anxious moment or two there but
they do get him down
[Applause]
hey
[Applause]
so it's halftime here on sports grandest
stage in the super bowl as we send you
to our ea studios in orlando here's
jonathan coachman with rea sports
halftime report okay brandon thanks very
much and welcome in everyone to an
abbreviated version of the ea sports
halftime report first things first
though let's get a check on the next gen
stats from that first half for new
england and there were a few factors as
to why they built this good size
advantage but the rushing numbers were
not all that amazing we'll see if they
can pick it up in the second half
meanwhile for the chiefs there's a look
at what they were able to do throwing
the football and they'll need to get
things in gear as they trail here at the
break all right coach thank you and we
welcome everyone back for quarter number
three
[Applause]
[Applause]
these two teams sat through a longer
than usual 30-minute wait but we're back
in action here in the super bowl
nicole hardman to return it from his end
zone and tackled at the 21-yard line so
a net negative there of four yards
here comes the chiefs offensive unit as
they'll have it to begin quarter number
three
and they're on the short end of the
scoreboard here charles what adjustments
if any do you think they need to make
for the second half we're paraphrasing
the gold medal hockey winning coach
brooks
i just say you continue to play your
game throw the ball they had success
doing it in the first half so make sure
you keep getting the ball to your
playmakers a little bit more to the
perimeter perhaps but above all
play your game the holmes will lead the
chiefs up first and ten at their own 21.
they start the second half here with
williams and he is brought down at the
22 after a gain of two and it brings up
second down
well it's not time to get them
established but in my estimation they've
got to pick up the urgency here they're
gonna get quickly in and out of the
huddle and run off a bunch more plays
from the 22 here's second and eight
mahomes gonna throw
and that one off the mark behind him
incomplete a lot of times it's that
first read that you have maybe you get
it in pre-snap he locked it on his
target but he was covered quite well and
that one's incomplete
[Music]
[Applause]
this offense in desperate need of a
conversion as they come up on third down
throwing now is mahomes
he is going to find hill here
and they're going to get this beyond the
40 before he's taken down
the kind of game he's had so far he had
to know that on third down that they
would be looking his way and they did
for big yardage and a first down i think
the defense fell asleep at the switch on
that one i would have doubled him
tripled him anything to keep the ball
out of his hands
mahomes now on first down
complete the tight end kelsey and he'll
be taken down but not before he gets in
the enemy territory
for a tight end he's got good straight
line speed and on that route he's often
the guy that gets overlooked nice job
there finding him in stride for really
good yardage
still in search of their first touchdown
of the game but they're on the move
first and ten
mahomes to throw once more gonna let one
fly for robinson
and that one a little too high as it's
knocked away and incomplete this defense
is continuing to contest every deep ball
that is thrown down field and look it
doesn't matter whether you're playing
man or zone eventually that becomes man
on man and you've got to trust yourself
and go up at that moment of truth and
make a play on the football
pass on first down that leads to a
second and ten
now here's mahomes
he finds his man complete it's watkins
and he's got another first down as the
tackle tackle's gonna be made at the
patriots 34 yard line i don't know what
they talked about at halftime whatever
it was it worked they looked like a
different team here in the third quarter
yeah i doubt that they're very made
trash cans and got kicked over that type
of a speech i think what they did was
they analyzed what worked in the first
half what didn't and figured out a
better game plan
on first down mahomes
and they're not able to hook up there
incomplete we've got to give out a
little applause on that play it has to
go to the defense more good work by them
they've taken away the passing lanes all
game long and you can see the
frustration that it's causing because he
just about threw that one into the first
row
from the 34 they'll come to the line on
second and 10.
to throw it's mahomes
and he'll win it over the middle
and he's got another first down as the
tackle's going to be made at the
patriots 21.
now what we're seeing this is much
better from this offense because so far
in this game no touchdown to this point
what's usually direct correlation very
few explosive plays that's been their
issue not able to make that big shot
downfield or break one off but a nice
game there for a first down
and nothing much materializing there on
the first down run he'll get a couple
and that's it
well they certainly had success throwing
the ball in this drive and not as much
running it as we just saw once again on
that last play stopped after a very
short gate but i wouldn't abandon the
run totally because otherwise pass
rushers just tee off on your quarterback
makes it very very difficult for him in
that situation
throwing on second and eight mahomes
and that's
kelsey touchdown kansas city
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and you know that there's an emphasis on
their side hey we know this we know
where we are but sometimes that binds
you up so much that you try too hard you
don't get the score a perfect
combination of urgency
yet relaxed enough to get it done
extra point by butker is on target and
that'll cut the lead down to a touchdown
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so that drive goes a full 80 yards and
10 plays and it winds up with the chiefs
hitting paydirt
[Applause]
now after the touchdown here's bucker on
to kick it away
now lewis selects to return it and only
able to get this to the 19 so probably
should have opted for the touch back
here comes the patriots offensive unit
they'll have it first here to begin the
third quarter and maybe some renewed
pressure on this unit following the
touchdown a moment ago it's back to a
one-score game and because of that
pressure because it's now a one-score
game
they know this is where you need to slow
the momentum change because otherwise
that could overrun your team you've got
to be careful right here
so brady and the pads take over first
and ten at their own 19-yard line
throwing to start the drive brady
and a first hook up with his all-pro
tied in rod gronkowski
and he'll be marked down all the way
inside the kc
a big play there on the catching one
[Applause]
you're watching the nfl kanye sports
back now here on ea sports
we get set for the fourth quarter
patriots have the lead they also have
the football
[Applause]
so first and goal six points here would
go a long way toward wrapping this one
up
brady gives this one to lewis and forget
about finding a lane he barely had time
to look up before he was playing it in
the backfield calling a full three yards
in the wrong direction there brings up
second down tackling's obviously
critical down near the goal line that
was great work there to make the hit
behind the line and make sure he doesn't
get any further did a really nice job
wrapping up and not letting him loose
[Applause]
moved back to the ten they'll try on
second and goal here
to throw it's brady
and he's gonna go down sacked right
around the 17.
chris jones breaking
[Music]
[Applause]
and ended up on the ground
[Applause]
a lot of tired bodies on that field but
this is a big play third and goal
on third down one
and he'll take this one down near the
15.
two yards on the pickup there it's
fourth down
this defense continues to be good on
third down they haven't allowed a
touchdown offensively are you saying
let's go for this let's try to get it in
the end zone i don't know about that
because of what you just described
they've been so good and they don't give
up the big play that you would expect in
downs one through three why should
fourth down be any different you might
want to go ahead and kick the field goal
and see if you can figure out something
else as this game moves on
[Music]
and goskowski's kick is good
and they double them up here that makes
our score 20 to 10.
so that one cd gonna make the road back
a lot more difficult oh there's no doubt
about that you know they were praying on
the other sideline for a miss because
now as you pointed out a very difficult
road down two scores you don't just need
a touchdown you need a chain of events
to go your way you've got to score
somehow get the ball back and score
again the odds of that happening not
great in your favor
[Applause]
the kickoff team on the field now as
they will send this one away
and hardman gonna go ahead and sit on
this one as it'll come out to the 25.
here comes mahomes and the chiefs down
20 to 10
just over two minutes to go
they've come so far this year but they
need two quick scores
late in this super bowl
[Music]
on first and ten here's mahomes a quick
slant to hill
and up to the 35 before they're able to
knock him down
[Applause]
so the chief's in possession of the ball
as we welcome you back
they've got a first and ten as they
search for a late score
mahomes throw caught by his receiver
hill
[Applause]
five yards on the catch there brings up
second down
short play like that in this situation
this late that's a win for the defense
no doubt i remember something coach
madden used to talk about all the time
sometimes you can't just take what the
defense gives you you have to take what
you need and in this case the offense is
taking what the defense is giving them
not what they need
[Applause]
it's a big play there for the chiefs of
course remember you need a touchdown
here and a field goal doesn't matter the
order but they have to get it done and
get it done fast
first down now but the clock continues
to move
[Music]
mahomes
and that nearly a turnover but it's
incomplete
fortunate to retain possession there
it's second down
that's certainly not the worst thing it
stops the clock and let your offense
catch its breath and lets us exhale a
little bit now i expect them to call a
couple plays in the home so they're
ready if a tackle happens in bounds so
now second and ten after the
incompletion on first down
mahomes
looking again for watkins and this time
that's complete and they'll get this
down to the 10.
they sure put the coverage guys into
stress on that one they thought they
were going deep ends up curling inside
for a nice chunk of yardage
first down now but that clock rolling
but it's incomplete
now the question is obvious do you try
to kick the field goal right here
knowing that you need two scores
i would be thinking about if i run that
sideline get the field goal now try and
get the touchdown later
so they'll come up after the
incompletion for second down
here's mahomes
and this is caught now for a late
touchdown so hold everything here this
one's not over yet okay game on don't go
anywhere yet you got a one score game
now
probably gonna rely on the onside kick
coming up yeah they have to it's not a
high percentage play but it's better
than not having a chance at all and
that's when you put your leapers and
your flyers on one side get that high
hop and hope that one of the guys can
come up with it and on the other side
get that hands team ready no doubt about
it
bunker on for the p.a.t
it's up and good and the leads now down
to three
[Applause]
[Music]
75 20-17 in seven plays and it's capped
off with a kansas city touchdown
[Music]
25 seconds to go
they must recover if they're gonna have
any chance
and the patriots are gonna recover and
that should just about assure victory
the risk reward of the onside kick when
you don't get it the wrist comes out to
play and here they gave up great field
position and that's the key to
everything because you're trying your
best
to press advantages when you have them
and field position leads you to that
type of play calling and whether you
want a blitz or whether you want to
throw the ball deep those types of
things not they've given up that type of
field position the advantages switch to
their opponent
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
they'll run on first down one and he'll
work this forward for about three at
second down
the chiefs will use the first of their
timeouts as the clock will stop with an
even 20 seconds left to go
the last run got three now here's second
and seven
again here's bloom
now a second timeout called for by the
defense
as they get it with 16 seconds remaining
on the clock
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
on third down one
and he is going to have the first down
and that is going to suck the life right
out of this crowd the chief's quickly
now gonna use the last of their timeouts
as he'll stop it with 11 seconds
remaining in the ball game
[Music]
[Applause]
line of scrimmage the 31 now on first
and 10.
time for this one final knee to put a
ball on this
[Music]
[Applause]
and it's another super bowl title for
the new england patriots
you